we like to think laws or where change
comes from it's like oh the law got
signed change happened
but in reality laws don't happen until
we come up with Norms we say hey that's
actually wrong like we believe that's
wrong and we come up with standards for
what it means to transcrust that Norm
and that process is is slower I think
there are ways that we can catalyze that
conversation and it should be a
conversation you know it should be a
public argument about what what do we
want our social media to do or what does
social media owe us because so much is
possible is all about establishing a
Groundswell of awareness and education
that puts pressure on legislators and
regulators